you can hear the fans getting into it
it's fun to be back here for sure
March Madness is here Making a Splash in
Las Vegas and casino Sportsbook say they
are reaping the benefits good evening to
you at 11 on this Thursday night I'm
Brian Lofts things are back in full
swing since the pandemic shut everything
down a few years ago this year one of
North America's biggest trade shows also
bringing hundreds of thousands right
here to Las Vegas Sasha Loftus joins us
live on the strip tonight with more on
the economic benefits this is also
bringing Sasha
Ryan everyone's talking about the vibe
here locally with the
cuspo taking over the Las Vegas
Convention Center as you can see behind
me then right next door that March
Madness betting is happening over at the
west gate now those who we spoke with
tonight say it's huge for everyone
involved
because
it reminds me of our version of
Christmas morning it's that time of year
again people pouring into Las Vegas from
across the country to watch college
basketball since I've been 20 we've been
coming from March Madness every year the
Westgate Sportsbook was packed Thursday
night as eager fans showed up to wait
with baited breath to see how their bets
and brackets fared the big dance is
always a win for our city with casinos
and sports books cashing in but this
year it also coincides with con Expo
I've never seen an expo at the same time
as March Madness it's definitely uh
worked out good for us I think Casey
degnan of Westgate Sportsbook calls this
an even bigger boost for them with about
130 000 people attending North America's
largest construction trade show right
next door for the first time since 2020.
it was almost sad during the pandemic
with March Madness this wasn't the same
and starting to get back to how it was
before so as you see more crowds descend
through this weekend and the rest of the
month no they're bringing plenty of good
things to look forward to in this Sports
state of mind everything you ever hear
and talk about is about college
basketball for four straight days it's
great
now many analysts are saying this is the
first quote normal con Expo will be
seeing since 2017 because the last one
happened right at the start of the
pandemic in 2020 the trade show itself
lasts through Saturday reporting live
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now